apple's m1 ultra chip within the max
studio is an absolute engineering marvel
that pushes the boundaries of
performance by combining two m1 max dies
together using their new ultra fusion
die to die interconnect technology but
i've been doing a ton of research over
the past week looking into how apple
could take this tech even further to
create essentially an m2 extreme chip
which would essentially be two ultras
stitched together for a total of four
dies creating basically the most
powerful chip you can find in a consumer
pc today breaking records left and right
and in this video i'm gonna explain
exactly how apple is gonna pull this off
in an easy to understand way as well as
how apple is gonna be able to cool it
down and also how much performance we
can expect to squeeze out of it and i
actually paid thirty dollars to download
tsmc's pdf file on their new fifth
generation calos s platform with their
brand new interposer which is used for
ultra fusion so i could learn exactly
how all of this is gonna work so if you
appreciate the effort click subscribe to
show your support now if you watched my
previous video on the m2 ultra duo i
based it on apple's 3d chip stacking
patents but because of some major leaks
that came in over this week i now
believe that it makes much more sense to
use a different method with the four
dies actually being joined side by side
like in this mock-up and before i get
into explaining how it's gonna work and
showing you guys a bunch of official
apple patent images from hours and hours
of research i want to explain why i no
longer believe the 3d stack chip design
is coming this year first of all mark
german was the number one reason why i
thought apple would go the chip stacking
route because it would actually be
possible with the m1 max dies which he
said would end up in a quad chip mac pro
with 40 cores but in his recent power on
newsletter he updated his leak to
include the likelihood of this quad chip
being based on the m2 max dies instead
which will actually be a 12 core chip
and this is a big deal because the m2
max could easily have two die to die
interconnects like you see in this image
so apple would just have to rotate them
around to combine them into a quad die
chair and this actually makes the most
sense because it'll be much easier to
cool because you'll have such a large
package area to place the heatsink onto
instead of dealing with a dual stacked
die package but going even further
imagine boot on twitter leaked an
official apple schematic showing not one
but three ultra fusion interposer
connections and right there in the
corner is exactly what it looks like a
quad die chip with ultra fusion
connecting it vertically and
horizontally and making it even better
this source who leaked the schematic
says that he believes this quad chip
will be shipping within a new mac pro by
september which makes a wwdc reveal
extremely likely and the best part about
this leak is that it perfectly matches
up to ross young's leak for a new
27-inch mini led display that he
believes will be shipping by september
as well and he even told me that he
expects it to be revealed at wwdc
alongside the mac pro so i'm basically
100 sure about the mac pro coming at
wwdc but getting back to that leaked
diagram you'll notice that there are
multiple ultrafusion interposer chips
with varying sizes and before i can
explain how these are going to connect
all four of the dyes you absolutely must
understand how the current m1 ultra
chips ultra fusion works first so let's
get into that within that pdf from tsmc
there are some licensed images that i
unfortunately can't show you guys but
thankfully they actually made some of
these public so check this out and this
kaos s progress slide tsmc literally
showed off an image of the m1 ultras
interposer which matches up to apple's
marketing image of the m1 ultra chip you
have two large areas for the two m1 max
dies and eight smaller areas for the ram
chips so everything is basically placed
right onto that interposer now if you
don't know what an interposer is tsmc's
latest version can be up to 2500
millimeters squared in size and it
actually features five layers where
there can literally be direct metal
connections stitched through it and if
you have a hard time imagining what the
silicon interposer looks like imagine a
big block of jello consisting of five
different layers which can house a bunch
of metal connections and signals between
the m2 max dies and the unified memory
chips and to better explain this i dug
through apple's patents and i found this
patent image which is actually flipped
upside down and as you can see
104a and 104b are actually two m1 max
dies and this right here in the middle
is quite literally five different layers
of ultrafusion metal stitchings
connecting both of the dies together and
if you don't believe me when i say
stitchings here's another patent image
that i found showing the stitchings from
the side and the best part about the
silicon interposer is that it can
actually be used for routing memory
channels as you can see in this image of
the interposer sitting between the pcb
substrate which is the motherboard and
the multiple chips with five layers of
interposer visible in the center but
making things even better
there can also be tsv's or through
silicon vias which can allow connections
to be made vertically from the chips
directly into the pcb using the
redistribution layer which sends signals
horizontally and allows connections to
those tsv's which means that everything
like the io and the thunderbolt
connections can actually travel down
through the interposer and into the
motherboard instead of having to use a
traditional connection like we have on
the m1 max chip and then finally there
can also be an active interposer where
apple can embed dedicated chips and
controllers to manage power usage and
different various signals and whatever
else they want to do but the main point
you need to know is that apple starts
with a chip package and then places a
silicon interposer on top of it that
consists of five different layers and a
redistribution fan out layer which is
essentially what apple is using to make
those over 10 000 wired stitching
connections between both m1 max dies to
create the m1 ultra chip and now with
that said let's finally get into how
apple is gonna make the quad die m2
extreme chip work first of all tsmc says
that their new high performance silicon
interposer is limited to 2500
millimeters squared in size which is not
going to be enough for the massive quad
die m2 extreme including all of the ram
chips that they need on the package but
if you actually purchase the pdf you get
access to a big secret apparently they
have something called quadruple mask
stitching which literally allows them to
take four interposer squares and stitch
them together for a massive interposer
and in tsmc's testing there were no
issues with stability while doing this
and yes i confirmed with the source that
apple is in fact using quadruple mass
stitching for the quadi chip but now
getting into how apple is gonna stitch
the four dice together the most
interesting part is that apple's code
name for this new chip is red fern which
was apparently the first high-end
sportswear brand potentially known for
its sophisticated level of stitching and
speaking of that stitching a secret
source has confirmed that there will be
a total of 12 ultra fusion connections
between the four dies so that's three
connections per die which explains why
the leaked diagram has three ultra
fusions shown so i ended up discussing
all of this with ta tech15 on twitter
who shares my fascination for this type
of stuff and he was able to draw up a
bunch of diagrams showing how all this
is gonna work as you can see we have two
ultra chips on the left and the right
which already contain ultra fusion
connections between the top and bottom
m2 max dies which are labeled daisy 1
and daisy 2. but one thing you'll notice
is that both of the top dies have two
ultra fusion connections between them
both a daisy xl narrow and a daisy xl
wide which was shown in that league at
the top right corner and if you're
wondering why there's two of them it's
probably to make sure that there's
enough bandwidth since you're going from
one m2 ultra chip over to the other and
then finally there's the daisy xl sub 2
which doesn't look like it makes sense
until you look at this little drawing
showing that this connection wraps all
of them together in a lower level of the
interposer kind of like in an l shape
and you'll also notice a couple of dots
which are actually the controller chips
within the active interposer which sends
signals and controls the different dies
and if this doesn't seem like it's
possible the source confirmed that each
max die will be edited to have paths
integrated into the silicon to make all
of those connections possible so it's
definitely going to be more complicated
than it seems kind of like this diagram
with connections going all over the
place and because of the combination of
12 total connections between all the
dyes i have no doubt that apple will be
able to achieve essentially two times
scaling in terms of raw performance
going from the ultra to the ultra duo or
the extreme so if this new chip was
based on m1 max dies that would mean a
geekbench 5 multi-core score of around
48 000 points which would be competing
with some of the best amd epic server
chips out there like the 7713
which has an msrp of seven thousand
dollars alone and a tdp of 225 watts and
the craziest thing of all is that the
maximum tdp on the new m2 extreme should
be around 120 watts so half the power
usage for around the same performance
but wait those numbers are based on m1
max dies and we're almost certain at
this point that the new extreme chip
will be based on the m2 max which is
rumored to be a 12 chord ship instead of
10 like on the m1 max and this means
that the m2 extreme will be even more
powerful especially since we know that
the m2 will at least be based on the a15
bionic chips cores which as you can see
in this image are quite a bit larger
than the cores on the a14 chip which the
m1 max is based on and because of that
ta tech 15 draw a diagram showing that
the m2 max die should be quite a bit
larger as you can see with the dotted
line and this is very important because
it's going to give them a bit more room
to fit memory channels and i o around
the top and the left sides while packing
the dye to die interconnects on both the
bottom and the right side in orange and
this is going to be the secret sauce to
the m2 extreme because they'll be able
to rotate this new m2 max die around the
package and combine them all together
like we saw in that leaked apple
schematic and now with that said there
are two more topics to talk about
including how apple is gonna deal with
the ram and pci express slot situation
as well as how they're gonna cool down
this chip according to imagine boost
source the daisy xl connection that goes
into the sub two layer of the interposer
can apparently access a separate memory
controller to access up to
one terabyte of memory yes i said one
terabyte and he even told us that
currently the one terabyte of ram has
slower access times than on the older
xeon mac pro which basically confirms
that apple is going to have extra ram
slots on the motherboard that directly
connect to the m2 extreme chip using
that daisy xl sub 2 connection with a
built-in controller so what we're most
likely to see is the m2 extreme coming
with
gigs of unified memory built onto the
actual package and then a bunch of extra
ram slots just so that the real pros who
need that much ram can still pay for it
however i was reading through tsmc's pdf
document and it mentioned that this new
fifth generation of calos s technology
supports eight stacks of hbm3 memory and
the beautiful thing about using hbm is
that it'll allow them to save a ton of
package space while greatly increasing
bandwidth and allowing for up to one
terabyte of memory on the package itself
but i think this is going to be way too
expensive and just overkill in terms of
the bandwidth so i think that apple is
going to be sticking to traditional lp
ddr ram especially since they can use
the interposer layers to route the ram
connections through the substrate which
hishnash on twitter has confirmed to me
and then they can get creative with the
ram placement like in these images that
hishnash mocked up or like in this
example that i made a few months ago in
this m1 max quad video and now as for
the pci express slot situation while i
personally don't think that they're
going to want to keep supporting
third-party amd graphics cards i do
think there's a very good chance that
apple is working on their very own
external gpu cards and the reason for my
speculation on this is a little
something called lyfuca which was a
leaked code name for a dedicated gpu
meant for the imac pro and that makes
sense because lifuka is an island on the
kingdom of tonga which just so happens
to be another code name for the m1 chip
so i believe by the whole island
codename apple's engineers implied that
this apple silicon gpu was meant to be
separated from the main soc package and
i think we'll be seeing it in the new
mac pro and i think it's going to be
directly connected to the m2 extreme
using the daisy xl sub 2 connection and
now finally for the cooling part of the
video since i don't think they'll be
stacking m2 ultra chips anymore it's
going to be a lot easier to cool so the
first thing we need to do is figure out
how much power the m2 extreme will take
which brings us back to the m1 max dye
which according to anandtech used a
maximum of 92 watts when both the cpu
and gpu were under a 100
stress load and keep in mind that this
is totally unrealistic and no regular
workload will make this happen but if we
multiply 92 by 4 dies we get
386 peak maximum wattage that will need
to be cooled for the worst case
scenarios and if that sounds like a
crazy amount it's absolutely not because
some of the gpus in apple's current mac
pro use up to 500 watts of power and
they're being cooled passively yes
passively with just a heat sink and the
mac pro's main three fans but going back
to the mac pro's announcement apple said
that the cpu's passive heatsink can
handle more than 300 watts of power and
not peak power but sustained 300 watts
so this basically leaves us with a gap
of 68 watts between those old xeons and
the new m2 extreme which i think apple
will have no problem cooling for a
couple of different reasons first of all
the tsmc pdf that i purchased details
two new thermal solutions including a
ring type package with dye backside
surface exposed for direct contact with
the heatsink which is something that
apple has already implemented on the m1
ultra in detailed public patents with
great success and they also mentioned a
new tim or thermal interface material
which allows them to bond the heatsink
plate directly over the chips for 100
coverage allowing for the least amount
of thermal resistance possible for
maximum heat transfer into the heat sink
and now the second reason is that apple
has already confirmed that they're using
a new much heavier copper heatsink in
the max studio to cool down the m1 ultra
chip which basically confirms that apple
will be using copper in the mac pro
cooler as well which will make it much
easier to cool down 368 watts of power
from the m2 extreme and to finish off
this video i once again think that the
mac pro will be revealed at wwdc and
ship in september and i think it'll
either come in the same exact chassis as
the current mac pro or they're gonna end
up shrinking it down by a little bit
potentially like this example that i
mocked up months ago so with that said
hopefully you enjoyed this video and if
you did go ahead and give me your
thoughts on all of this down in the
comment section below and click the
circle about to subscribe because we're
about to begin massive amounts of mac
studio testing this week so thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]